okay how do i record the guys
in this situation mike's grabbing my
hand i'm going to step
offline as i begin all my techniques i'm
going to come to offline right so
the limits amount of power you can make
towards me makes him start moving which
are all things i want
and this i'm going to step up to 45 and
bring my hand up again if i brought this
hand up violently it's possible that i'm
just going to break my hand free but
mike sticks right with me
i bring this hand in to aid me grab here
and sink
everything down now notice i'm using the
palm of my hand against the back of my
hand
i'm not using my thumb it takes a lot of
abuse when i don't take a lot of abuse
here trying to apply this way
instead if i use my thumb as a latch
just to hold on to mike and use the palm
of my hand
i can apply a lot of force in the mic
here i bring him down
from here i'm going to step my back leg
across my head now the reason i want to
do this
if mike had a weapon in his hand and i
step across like this he can easily cut
my femoral artery
right that's it it's going to be really
bad day for me after that if i step this
way i'm still going to get cut but not
nearly as badly right so he might cut my
quadricep that'd be really bad because i
couldn't walk from here but in the next
movement i could easily situate that in
the pin by when i fall down
from here i'm going to step across and
pull my as hard as i can
into my shin so i'm trying to pull my
right into my shin
hopefully i'll knock a little the air
out of him and take a little to fight
out
from here i'm going to place his hand on
my thigh and i'm driving his shoulder
straight down the mat
the other hand goes to his elbow and i
drive his elbow down so i'm getting both
his shoulder
and elbow in this one pin i drive
everything straight in
my gives me the tap
one more time to speed
is